who's got school spirit
not me
you guys this episode is insane um i
want to let you know that my shows are
literally just a few weeks away and
they're selling out and i am so excited
to come and meet you all in portland san
francisco and finally new york city is
on sale all those are available at
esteronice.com this is the time to buy
them if you're coming it's just a few
weeks away and they're very close to
being sold out and also
sleepoverbyester.com for the new drop of
oh my god the grape
wine like it's called i spilled my
grandma's wine sweat suit it's i've been
living in it i'd be wearing it now but
george has been a cheerleaders outfit no
swearing in the first five minutes of uh
bleep it out george
see you guys all right sluggies come see
me live i am coming to a club near you
hopefully you can see me next october
22nd through 23rd in san antonio texas
at the laugh out loud comedy club i will
be bringing josh potter with me i'll be
at skankfest november 55th through 7th
in houston texas i'll be at the house of
comedy in plano november 11th to 14th
irvine comedy uh irvine improv december
2nd
uh i'll be back in texas at cap city in
austin december 9th through 11th i will
be in new jersey september 16th through
18th at bananas comedy club and uh
that's then the new year just look it up
online at annieletterman.com shows i've
got a bunch more up there come see me
it's so fun
[Music]
esther how are you i'm so good i feel
insane how are you
i just usually when people feel insane
they don't feel so good no no and vermee
insane is usually good oh the only bad
thing to be for me is bored
i don't want to ever be bored but if i'm
like crazy that's that's good you know
why why because you're broken
i learned this when i went to a facility
with bobby
healing is in the boredom we always
label peace and quiet
and self-reflection as boredom yes um
chaos is in the this you know i mean all
of the
insanity you're feeling it's because a
lot of things are happening you probably
feel a little untethered and it's fun
and it's so destructive so i i am are
you saying i am bipolar manic depressed
i would say you're really riding on a
mania right now no i'm genuinely not
even like that no no i'm not stop
no i'm just you stop right there
honestly i enjoy my mania i have no
shame in my mind
i'm just excited to tell you
because it's on theme i have something
to share about high school you know was
we're in our cheerleading outfit right
i'm really excited to get it off my
chest welcome by the way to the
cheerleader episode of trash tuesday ra
ra
i don't know
did you were you you were not a
cheerleader look at my shoulders and ask
me that question again
look at your hot body and ask you are
you a cheerleader no this is a rig
esther this is made for the pool when
you have a wide back
and you're
you look the way i do i should be in a
sport in the water
thing that i ever like before deciding
if i can do something look at my body
and say like i should i or shouldn't i
[ __ ] no
i am a sh i'm a five foot tall girl who
tried to be a rockette for years wait
but that's a perfect height to be a
rockette right no rockettes you
literally have to be like five nine or
you can't apply wait but it's so rare to
have super tall like gymnasts right
rockettes are dancers but don't they
have usually some background in like
they can i always just assume like
dancers have a background in like some
gymnastics
and doesn't gymnastics like sort of
stunt your growth
look if you want to get technical
okay rockettes must be between 5 6 and 5
10.
i had literally zero chance and i was
like uh let me just see
why don't you get your bones stretched
in china is that real cause when i was
little my dad was like you could go in
the stretching machine and i was like
really and he's like i made it up i saw
this thing on instagram where this guy
gained like five inches
he was five three and now he's five
eight he's about my height now limb
lengthening
this can't be safe it can't be why do
you always know like the unsafe ways to
improve
the asians you know
they tell me
yeah they feed me this information my
asian mafia does and the jews are like
we're just gonna stay as we are
really we know what we are there's not
really much we can do to fix okay can i
tell you
this
this this crazy thing that happened
my i told you how recently i reconnected
with my one of my best guy friends from
high school is that the one who
professed his love for you yeah okay and
when i hung out with him like a couple
weeks ago in my hometown he was like by
the way i have this video
that you made senior year for like a
project and i was like oh my god i've
actually been looking for that video
he had like all the raw footage
from this like senior project i made
it's my high school boyfriend um
interviewing me asking me questions
about my high school experience yeah and
i'm so
weird and goofy and like i talk like a
baby like but i look exactly how i do
now like it's so weird to watch chrissy
look exactly like you literally look
exactly the same and
there's like then there you cut to me
like walking around my high school so it
was so cool like i'm like have this time
capsule i'm watching it this weekend
when i was in mexico and
all of a sudden it cuts to three seconds
of me having graphic sex
with my high school boyfriend stop use
the same tape
literally as though it's a nightmare or
a movie that i'm in where the worst case
scenario happens
it's three seconds of me crawling
[ __ ] butt ass naked up my boyfriend
in high school's body and i'm starting
to make out with him
we're mid graphic sex you are the sex
tape kind of gal i only in high school
yes i literally cut it off after high
school because i told dave what happened
and he was like what we never i was like
dave you cannot film
that stuff but i just couldn't [ __ ]
believe it so basically i'm guessing
like this was my tape can i watch i will
show it to you okay i have it digitized
for that's how i got to see it
but and then i told my friend i was like
just so you know
and he said he had no idea he'd never
watched the chat is he are you sure
about that i doesn't seem like a lie it
does seem like a lie and he was like i
won't watch it i was like i don't care i
was like you already have it
i was so freaked out when i saw it and
then i came to terms i was like my
friend ben already has his tape he's
allowed to look at it like but no one
else can see it i am also i think it
might be like illegal child porn yes
i just couldn't believe what i saw and
honestly was i at first i was like oh my
god holy [ __ ] and then later as like it
was sitting with me i feel traumatized
by it like to see my teen self like
[ __ ] some dude and like i look my
body looks so good
how traumatized were you oh my god my
my ass
and my perky [ __ ] tits and i was
skinny as [ __ ] i look so good
beauty is wasted on the youth it acts i
look so good and i'm like i'm just
[ __ ] this guy like it was it's
traumatizing have you ever seen yourself
having sex with an ex
yes
you're like yes i jerk off to it i do
it depends which eggs
now usually like here's what i'll say
about that esther i think that there is
something traumatizing because you're
not in a place of like feeling sure
about yourself at that age at all and
the way you describe it like you're
crawling imagine all the angst and
insecurity we felt at that time even
around the idea of sex and boys liking
us back and just all of it right so that
probably throws you back there yes and
it looks like i'm like this like
performative like sexual being but i'm
like i'm an actual legal child i need
you to sign a consent before i watch
this because i feel like i'd be watching
kitty porn i actually want nothing more
than for you to watch it and then to get
your opinion on it because it's so to me
so graphic are you gonna delete it
tell me the truth no i'm not going to
delete it that's the truth okay because
i have it on one big file with all this
other like high school gold that's going
to be used for something i don't know
what but okay why don't you split it
into two separate digitized
um
things so you don't have to watch one
with the other
in the event that you want to watch the
high school stuff and not the crawling
on someone's body stuff
i feel like once you've seen it you've
seen it and like you can handle it like
i don't need to
but one thing is i told dave and i was
like dave do you want to see it
and at first he was like i don't see why
not and then he was like actually no
yeah i'm like would you well here's what
i'll say about bobby um he did find some
pictures of me in mexico as a 17 year
old
now i was actually 18 already at this
time but i was a papasan beer
and i had my top off at a bar and i had
some random boobs sucking on my tits
because that's where the tequila or the
salt was they put the salt rim around my
tits some dude was about to take a shot
um and he
was genuinely like
sad what do you explain i don't know
you'd have to ask him but he was just
like i don't know what it is he's like i
wish i'd never seen that like you're
like you were you were a child that dude
you know what i mean
yeah like it just made him sad he was
like
i think that this would make dave really
like depressed
yeah but but i still want to show it to
him
badly because i look so good are you
going to trick him into watching him no
i'm not evil that's like sickening what
you just suggested is very ill
and i'm not that level but part of me
wants him to see how hot i was but also
that's crazy
because you're hot now yeah to him for
sure i actually think i i'd be willing
to bet you're hotter now than ever
you've ever been i agree
especially because i do actually believe
hotness is
comes from your essence and i think my
essence is super hot right now i feel i
i've never felt hotter in my life i
agree you are so [ __ ] hot
the light's dim the music plays
show me that tape
no your essence is as hot as it's ever
been no yours but i do have okay we
didn't have the fancy um
gadgets in blair high school so all we
had we couldn't we didn't have the fancy
cell phones we couldn't record ourselves
having sex this was our video camera
just to clarify we didn't have like
money for that fair enough didn't have a
computer didn't have that stuff but my
ex-boyfriend sergio did have a polaroid
camera
and he did take
i mean the craziest nudes of me like i
was just so down at that age i don't
know how i was like yeah take a close-up
shot of my [ __ ] lips oh my god
like just up close just get into that
[ __ ] cervix like i was just
insane apparently like i would never
have allowed anyone to do that unless
for like medical purposes now yeah no
i'm all about the silhouette now i'm
like no take it from afar i agree you're
on six filters it is about a silhouette
yeah yeah no that is it it's weird when
you're you're actually a kid and you are
able to do all these sexual things and
it's like they're not you're not all
there bro
i'm not i mean i would have sex like in
like
a dugout
in a baseball field you know like the
craziest places that i would resort to
to just get it in because i was just a
horny teenager it's kind of embarrassing
and it wasn't for the thrill of being
like exhibitionist it was because i had
nowhere else to [ __ ]
it's embarrassing and i'm glad we're
sharing it with
the 200 000 people will watch this video
next tuesday so my final take on this
whole thing and maybe annie will have a
different take on it when she gets here
is that um
um it's nice
the time capsule thing i'm really happy
for
um same and you know what i really like
is the fact that you felt good watching
an older version of yourself because
when i watched a video of myself in high
school
i think i cried for three days why i
could not recognize who she was all i
saw was somebody with a very thick
accent trying to sound like a valley
girl trying to like mask an accent and
everything came flying back and i wanted
to die watching it because you're so
humiliated humiliated oh my
from goodness different time
you look like one that died in 1920
what do i look like well i'm just only
seeing your eye makeup um
so there are eras of cheerleading annie
i love you we're from different eras of
cheerleading i love that you did the
classic thing today of being late but
with starbucks in your hand starbucks
became i will tell you this starbucks
came way before the late
starbucks was very early this morning it
has kind of a bulls vibe to it so that's
why i really like it
oh like uh what were those the lovables
were these
like the chicago bulls right the chicago
bulls no the lovables were the chicago
bulls damn like l.a like the lakers i
don't know that i'm not gonna know that
i used to babysit for a lovable and she
was so gorgeous wait you babysit a
lovable no i was trying to babysitter
for her babies oh okay got it show us
these now i saw these in your pictures
from adam devine's wedding yes did you
wear them with a dress i did
i wore them with a skirt okay got it um
esther can you i know that you wanted
desperately to be a rocket could you
show us another yeah show us now well
you teach us to you have cute little
strong legs wait really yeah explain
they're like more look like maybe you
ran once but we know you didn't
like maybe you went on a bike or it's
from it's honestly from ballet from high
school it's still do you have [ __ ] up
toes from like did you have a point i
did do point but my toes didn't get
[ __ ] up from it
well this is actually cheer this is
palms because i was on the palm spot i
love the unshaved armpits mine too
yesterday
i wait do you guys have five o'clock
shadow every time you shoot yes i can't
do a kick in this well we'll blur it out
show us your labe
papa labe
stop don't say that
didn't sleep at all last night i didn't
need anything because your legs were
moving of course you would have
russell's legs no do you know what i'm
talking about where like you get these
tingles all in your lower and you feel
the urge to like run and move what do i
have restless leg syndrome how do i make
it
my sister has really bad restless leg
syndrome because she has a bad back and
she injured it really young so i don't
know she hasn't found a solution but
when she does i'll let you know i just
want to be clear i believe in russell's
leg syndrome i do not believe in
esther's restless legs
no i had too convenient i had it once
like five years ago and then it went
away really easily but it's back and it
sucks do you think it's like your body
wants to move yes that's my theory no i
think maybe you don't move enough and
your body's like it's time that's why
your legs are good i was hoping it's
because um i i was on a plane yesterday
maybe that triggered it
is that your tell us about your trip i
usually i usually get restless leg after
a big heavy night out of drinking and
that my knees and legs feel weird at
when i'm hungover it's just like
just gout but like instead of like
just
jaeger around my joints
you're in your joints there's so much
butt cheek hanging i wish you guys could
see i wore a little shoulder
way too small give us a breakdown please
god your [ __ ] thighs are [ __ ] epic
oh my god he says christ
i well i wanted to wear a pantyhose i
was trying to get like a
dallas cowboys slash hooters kind of
vibe with the legs with the you know
yeah
and then i put the shorts on underneath
and um i ordered this online it's just
so short and what does it say in the
front cause your hair is covering it
says daddy oh that's sick
that's just like imagine i wasn't
wearing the shorts
i mean
my ass hair would be
in the face
tell us about mexico okay so i went to
mexico for adam devine's wedding i'm so
excited to go to where in mexico cabo
cabo at a really nice resort it was so
beautiful i've never i've never
gone on a real vacation you've been to
mexico though i have been
in high school i went once i mean i went
in college twice with my parents so it
was very much like the third wheel vibe
but this was it was
so fun eric griffin was there adam ray
was there
um
i don't i'm divine was there adam devine
was there
um
it was just really fun i don't know oh
my god adam and blake a few people came
up to me and and adam rayne everyone was
so complimentary of trash tuesday
come on boys let's do a workaholics
episode
that's been off the air for five years
but it's still good
what if i was like i love is my favorite
show
no i would love to have them on this
though i i almost was like well if you
love it so much but i was like i'll play
it cool but no they were so everyone at
the wedding was not everyone but all the
comedy people were like made up in the
middle of it was like and um grab her
hand first i do want to say before they
kiss i want to say i love trash tuesdays
help me sometimes your friends cannot
hear you complain more kalila you've had
to set some boundaries with me before
you guys
if you are a fan of this show you know
that myself annie and esther we have a
long list of problems and there is no
shame
in upping your mental
wellness game and we at this show do it
with better help check out
betterhelp.com
trash tuesday so a lot of things
interfere with my happiness i know that
i go through
especially right now in the fall i have
seasonal um effective disorder effective
disorder i have the sads
and it really ramps up in november right
around my birthday
and i think if you and annie has her own
set of issues as well
and that's what interferes with ours but
betterhelp will assess your needs and
match you with your own licensed
professional therapist connect in a safe
and private online environment it's so
convenient you can start communicating
in under 48 hours
it's not a crisis line it's not
self-help it is professional counseling
done securely online you can send a
message to your counselor anytime and
you'll get timely and thoughtful
responses plus you can schedule weekly
video or phone sessions because
sometimes i don't want to see anybody
and those phone sessions really come in
handy let traffic be the only thing
that's blocking you
anything you share is confidential it's
convenient professional affordable you
guys we want you to start living a
happier life today
as a listener you'll get 10 off your
first month by visiting our sponsor at
betterhelp.com
trash tuesday join over one million
people who have taken charge of their
mental health again that's betterhelp
h-e-l-p dot com slash trash tuesday
we're all trying to eat better listen
i'm getting high i don't i'm smoking
weed i don't know what to eat okay i'm
running around my house i'm getting top
ramen i'm i'm eating funyuns i'm i'm
eating things that are not good for you
i have a solution to your munchies
why not instead of grabbing that
cereal with a chock full of sugar
that you just reach for that
magic box
of magic spoon i i'm so down i can't
even like here when i put things away in
my cabinet i don't think of them when
i'm high i'm gonna put my magic spoon
out on the
you know what my mom does for me she
makes um uh rice krispie treats using
magic spoon and it's just i get to eat
it without the
sugars um growing up cereal was one of
the best parts of being a kid wouldn't
you agree yeah but
why did we have to give it up
it just was it was bad for us we didn't
we couldn't do anymore it's like what
are we gonna eat we're all trying to eat
better but healthy breakfast doesn't
have to be boring magic spoon has the
amazing flavors you love but without all
the bad stuff and it's amazing as a
midnight snack it has zero grams of
sugar 13 to 14 grams of protein and only
four net grams of carbs in each serving
only 140 calories a serving that's keto
friendly gluten free grain free soy free
and low carb
what i love about is that you can
actually build your own box depending on
which flavors you love and they have
flavors from cocoa to fruity
frosted for a very simple gal like me i
love the frosted peanut butter blueberry
cinnamon cookies and cream and maple
waffle
we also just want you guys to know that
magic spoon has brought back the two
most popular flavors cookies and cream
and maple waffle and they are now here
to stay so you guys can go to
magicspoon.com tuesday to grab a custom
bundle of cereal and try it today and be
sure to use our promo code tuesday at
checkout to save five dollars off your
order and magic spoon is so confident in
their product it's backed with a 100
happiness guarantee so if you don't like
it for any reason they'll refund your
money no questions asked remember get
your
next delicious bowl of guilt-free cereal
at magicspoon.com
tuesday and use the code tuesday to save
five dollars off we thank magic spoon
for sponsoring this episode and we love
them so much
wait did they have like a cool what do
you call the person that marries you
priest oh no it was adam ray officiated
it oh i know and he did great he was
funny i was wondering if you guys would
ever be interested in officiating a
wedding and you think you'd be good at
it are you going to make us compete to
officially i would love to of course i
would be good at it i would be really
good at it too in ways you wouldn't even
expect like how esther i can't even
explain it like you wouldn't expect to
be good and then she would do it you
would expect her to not show up and then
she'd be there opening with complaining
about your restless leg syndrome i would
i would put i would just work so
tirelessly on it because i know
how good they have to be for it you know
and yeah it needs to be you need it
really needs to be good i do blame the
um the person who marries the people if
they get a divorce
how why well it's just your fault you're
supposed to this is your ceiling your
bonding yeah situation if you didn't do
it you could read some of your poetry do
you blonde hair now i don't that's just
an extension oh it's beautiful thank you
i thought you were doing esther's
although i did used to have ashy
a highlights but i feel like that phase
is so i want you to do chunky highlights
because i did but high school i was all
about the chunky i just don't think i
could pull it off now your eye makeup
looks great thank you annie
i want to just go back i will say that
it did feel like i was at like a
workaholic like i was in like the
wedding did they seat you guys together
they're all uh what do you mean the
comics no no i was shocked i wasn't at
eric griffin's table eric griffin was at
the table with rebel wilson and i was i
was with blake and some of blake's
friends and obviously dave because dave
is
i don't i only know those guys through
dave um because dave wrote on the first
two seasons i think and they're
they're all so like i love the
brotherhood of that they have so cute
it's inspiring to me like that we need
to have that for us which one are we
which which one of them are we
you're adam because you're like the wild
crazy one oh you're short don't you
[ __ ] say eric's character no you're
not montez
you're crystalia you're crystalia's
character no but you know what's so
funny is when we got there dave saw
aircraft he's like montez and i'm like
that's so that that's what you know him
like i see him every night i do think
i'm ders
okay honors
yeah george is not dead
because i feel like i'm like kind of the
nerdiest of the bunch endures i feel
like
is like gets it done
i it's so weird what you think you are
i'm am i so surprised do you think i'm a
jock
annie thinks i'm a jock so i think she's
a jock
i don't think you are in the world
anything thanks world or actually your
montez
you're definitely montez i'm just
kidding you're not montez
you're probably jillian bell's character
what was eric's
character just like the goofy guy in the
office he's just eric that's definitely
not me he's himself you mean yeah yeah
no you have to be blake then
why are you looking at me like that i'm
drinking you in
drinking yen
she's always in hawaii coming back
glowing do i look pregnant again no you
look great i don't you didn't look
pregnant last time you looked like you
had gotten fillers or something or botox
and from hawaii you mean yes so the tan
will do but my tan is faded so the
fillers the botox look is gone i hold
this by the way because my hands sweat a
lot so if you receive that and it annoys
you trust me this is a coping mechanism
we've been through this yeah i know i
just need to remind you but i want
everyone to know that she has a whole
that's i'm convinced that trump all of
your like ailments are things that just
make you hotter to men because like you
have sweaty hands so it's like a hand
job like it's true you said that you
can't grow your vagina hair
yeah
that is true
god is just gifting me all of these but
that ass hair really does grow the ass
hair is a problem it's frowing out you
know what i hate to tell you guys but
that's coming that's
the growth has stopped there too
well i manscaped
i do a light manscaping and then i kind
of just left let's be honest there's
nothing light about your man
the light the led light
i manscape but it's not it's very sloppy
guys do have
power when they make you feel a little
like they could leave you at any point
like the fact that i know todd will be
with me till my last breath i really do
very little for him
it is true they got to keep you kind of
thirsty yeah he needs to flirt with
someone in front of him he never he's so
he's such a good boy i'm like you gotta
do something why is that i god that is a
terrible thing about me
what is that when i'm shown like total
love and devotion it's um
it's almost like i don't know what to do
with it because it's not what i'm
familiar with like my mom kept me
thirsty for her love i'm still thirsty
for her you know um
like some validation from her so it's
like those are the types of relationship
i had growing up so it's the same ones
that i have with men so
my ex was
probably the greatest guy you could ever
meet i just could not get there yeah and
because i was young and stupid maybe now
okay let's try it let's bring it back on
but why are bobby's down why does it
work with bobby but it didn't work with
the x because it keeps me so thirsty he
gives me no love and affection i'm just
always like can you just touch my hair
today
i have a question for you guys if you
were to ask one of your exes what your
ass tastes like what would they say
what who are you first of all
you're talking about
no no no i i saw my ex the other night
oh you did so i see him okay so i'm with
i'm with todd we're out smoking weed
after the after the show
after my spot and my ex-boyfriend comes
to the commie store and he calls me over
right and i so i go to i go to tata go
i'm gonna go talk to him
so i walk over my ex-boyfriend thinking
i don't know what i thought was gonna
happen i just thought it was gonna be
good he goes immediately he goes hey do
you want to see this thing i made and i
went i said no
i don't want to see it
and he kept he started explaining it to
me rather than showing it to me and i
couldn't believe it and i was so high
and i didn't want to talk to him at all
and i started like recoiling and this
open micro who was like rolling a blunt
next to us was like he walked away and
he goes was that guy a manager and i go
no he's a comedian which was perfect
awesome i was like oh my god nobody
knows who he is and he like well and i
go no and he goes what was why was that
so crazy and i went i
he's my ex-boyfriend and he was like
that's why you were recoiling i was like
the whole time i was like this he was
speaking at me i hated every second of
it i kept trying to say things to him
and it felt like it felt like my words
would come out and they weighed too much
to like keep going so they would fall to
the ground yeah just like
like i just have nothing my energy
cannot be near him i feel very
protective of you when you talk about
like
even being around him because
of how toxic
you described it
like
takes two to have a crazy rage i
realized that but like some of the
sexual stuff that you talk to me about
makes me wanna [ __ ] cry and i think
that's what your body probably responds
to whoa i mean
it could be i mean i think it might be
but it's just i don't i can't belie what
i feel is not like anything about him
it's more like sadness for who i was
that i dated this person that i was with
this person for so long that i idolized
this person i loved this person yeah
this is very on trend with what we were
talking about before you got here
because i [ __ ]
watched a tape of mine from high school
and intercut
not fully taped over was three seconds
of graphic sex with my high school
boyfriend
yeah you are such you're secretly the
biggest [ __ ] in this whole crew it's
really you're the go-go queen she's
getting her little bell [ __ ] you
sick of your [ __ ] ring the bell with a
graphic sex tape
is like the first time you've rung the
bell on yourself
you baby [ __ ]
but like at first at first like oh my
god my body's hot amazing and then
you're like oh i feel sick i was like
there to have sex with this gross guy
like no disrespect to him but like
i don't know it was just it made me it
made me uncomfortable and i thought
about it later and it made me feel sad
it's just like you're seeing this
version of yourself or something like
imagine if you saw yourself having sex
with one of these oh it's disgusting why
is that it's so bad i just realized that
i was in a relationship for two years
with someone that did not give a [ __ ]
anything i said anything i wanted
anything i needed was not even and if he
did it was because it was like to feed
him being able to tell me more but as
someone who talks at people i can also
understand that but you know what's good
about you is that you listen
and there's pieces of information that
i've thrown at you where i'm like how
the [ __ ] does she remember that and now
i'm like insecure that i'm like what
have i said to annie because she you
retain stuff yeah you're not a talker
who doesn't also listen yeah like you
you do both you are good at getting
information out i don't know if you
sound really good but i don't know if
you keep it you've never thrown it back
at me i definitely keep it and i don't
use it against you and throw it back at
you no i've definitely like
been in conversations with you where
i've gotten off the phone and going i
don't think she said one
word except oh really what else
and i'm like what is she doing is she
writing a book
no that is truly my jam like i
i love to just i mean i feel like you're
like me too we talked all the time it's
like i just am a listener and i love to
ask questions and like you you also
there's a reason like we have a podcast
that's like also you have a lot to say
you know you're a machine and people are
interested yeah i wasn't alone
that was just me discovering that we
should do a podcast did you learn
that skill set
to extract info
no i think that's literally just who i
am yeah it's not like a skill to me yeah
so one of your parents do it my mom's
super nosy and like is a big listener
yeah is she a big gossiper no she's a
she's her she's so genuine like she just
loves to list that i truly it's not a
gossip thing for me i love that i love
to just listen and learn about people
it's to me that's better than like
watching a tv show i yearn for someone
like your mom because my family the
women in my family couldn't shut the
[ __ ] up about other people yeah like it
was just like always gossip central and
it drives me crazy like even my mom now
like i wish we had deeper conversations
like it's so superficial it's always
about who's gained weight whether it's a
celebrity or someone we know who's
broken up with who who's like in
financial ruin you know it's always like
the yeah like how bad they're doing
that's fun it does uplift you a little
it gives you a little boost
yeah i always i always tell her it's
like ma you know like you're operating
on like the lowest frequency right where
you're just talking about other people
i was like i don't care i feel still
because i'm i'm i'm working on my
gossiping and i'm working on like
just that the activity of it when it's
like completely separate from everything
else like it's one thing when you're
like hanging out with someone you're
working on something you do a little
gossiping during it or whatever but when
your whole
hang is a gossip like from start to
finish or just talking [ __ ] like
remember that girl i used to be friends
with that's all that was how we became
friends and when we ended up not being
friends anymore it was like of course
this friendship wasn't gonna last
because it was completely based on like
like just trashing everyone all the time
which is some more comics we can do it
well we have like good kids it can be
very fun yeah yeah i'm not saying that i
want it out of my life but i've realized
like i've been noticing more what i hate
is when my friends
goss about something i've never met
where i'm like there's no product we
can't like talk through it we can't like
i like to gossip with now with like a
goal of getting through it yeah and
figuring out what is the thing about
that person that's like
reflecting on you like how do you get
out of this what does this mean right so
when my friend will bring up
she'll like bring up a girl i'm not
friends with and she'll just be telling
me about like what happened to that girl
one day who cares
what
this is for this is literally a waste of
time i don't know that person
that it couldn't be more true
i cannot stand people who go on and on
and on about a sheila that i've never
met and i'm like who the [ __ ] is sheila
like why do i care and then they need
you to care with them like i'm like
yeah like you're not even gonna believe
what happened to the to this girl like
she went out one night and this girl
said something about her and i'm like i
don't i don't know this girl i didn't
know she was married i don't
and then i'll go oh i don't want to talk
about this yeah and then it's like very
like well i'm upset i'm like but why are
you upset about a thing that has nothing
to if you have a problem with this
person i'll talk to you about that all
night did something happen to you with
this person that you want to talk
through but what there's no like
our longest conversations between the
three of us like my favorite thing was
when i told you about this one person
and i felt really sort of like
like oh like i don't know about this
person but this person i feel like
she's doing this and that and you guys
just backed me up and validated it with
your own story
and i was like oh my god i don't feel
crazy i love those instances where i'm
like am i feeling crazy but i feel like
this person is doing this and then you
guys give me your own
that's what i get into too because i'm
genuinely like not that i'm a listener
but i'm not really like
out for the gossip i actually would
rather i would much rather sit and have
annie tell me like all about herself
like that's so much more interesting oh
good thing
i got a lot to say about me you're in
the right place
um
but on the other side of that is like
when they're
there's like if someone is actually like
a like has been mean to you and done
something bad to you and then you hear
that they did something bad to someone
else you know
time to be like all right here's what
happened
todd always says this he says he got
scammed once really bad i can't remember
what it was
it was someone
like he got scammed in like a really
like kind of obvious way where someone
like wanted to borrow money from him it
was just some random thing where he got
scammed and he said once you get scammed
you just want to find other people that
got scammed it's like true yeah it's
just community so you know another
person yeah
hell yeah by the way that's literally
why you guys talking about being
molested is [ __ ]
genius and incredible for the world
thank you so much no because other
people want to hear that
it's
that is and most people don't want to
say that
not anymore not at my shows not in my
meet and greets just like that
we got some meaty meet-and-greets
we get to it
should i call an ex and ask him how much
[ __ ] tastes oh my god
she had a she had a goal here well no
it's just because like bobby has never
ever
what he's never even tasted it
your ass never why not
he's kind of a prude actually like he's
not a like we we freaky role play but we
don't like do like a lot of freaky
things
you don't tootsie roll play unless you
guys wanna
be my [ __ ] i would literally eat your
ass i don't care oh my god you guys and
again we bring us back to our only fans
guys it's gonna be five thousand dollars
it's not even sexual i would just want
to like taste it it wouldn't even be
like i would not be getting it off i
would just be like this is cool
i like that i'm doing this
i
if i knew for sure that you had showered
recently
wait is that a pikmi girl thing to say
pick me gay i said
[Laughter]
esther it's weird that every episode
there's some sort of like it's
proposition no i y'all crawl over and do
something sexual i just think like a
woman's [ __ ] is probably very clean
like i know i know what i do mine's very
clean i trust like i don't think it's
that big of a deal there's no way your
[ __ ] is really clean
i've seen the state of your hair on the
top of your head
you think the private parts are cleaner
than the outward part they are
that's sick
would you not eat kalila's ass seriously
think about it for a second you wouldn't
just be there's always a price
there's always a price so this is purely
for ratings
for ratings sure yeah i mean and that's
it would just be a very i've never said
no to eating tarantulas
i'll do whatever anyone asked me to do
because i never back down is that the
snack for the day each other's [ __ ]
is that the food challenge
you guys today's episode is sponsored by
our friends at manscape the leaders in
men's below the waste grooming it's back
to school time and we want to make sure
your man is packing the essentials to
have his best year yet the manscaped 4th
generation performance package is just
that we can't have all those pencils
he's putting in his uh
holes getting caught up in pubes
it is it's the perfect package for his
package which includes the brand new
lawnmower 4.0 get him the valedictorian
of ball trimming so he can join the 2
million men worldwide who trust
manscaped by going to manscape.com
codetrash this package includes the
brand new lawnmower 4.0 and will give
him the confidence to do anything you
desire send them to smooth balls
university to learn a thing or two annie
listen it's sparse the chemo hair it's
it's in different chunks it's never
consistent get rid of all of it if
you're thinking i want to keep some
because it's thinning in other areas get
rid of all the ball here we don't want
it right and you guys it's not that for
me it's not that i care that there's
hair there i just need to know there's a
little bit of effort in terms of
grooming it's such a compliment to me
you're like you know what i care about
you
and how and also because my my face is
right there yeah so it's like just a
little bit of consideration it goes a
very very long way the lawnmower 4.0
also has a 7000 rpm motor a new
multi-function on and off switch that
can engage a travel lock in any they
have that 4000
led spot 4000k led spotlight that you
talked about no hairs get left behind
and did you know that it was waterproof
as well so you can have a precision in
the shower i do i get very horny when i
shave so it has to be
seal the deal with manscapes liquid
formulations before heading out with
your mans he can use the crop preserver
ball deodorant to keep him going in the
heat
then after he trims the lawn and whacks
the weed in the heat he can give his
balls a boost and use the crop revival
thank you again get 20
off plus free shipping with the code
trash at manscaped.com that's 20 off and
free shipping with the code trash at
manscape.com this year have your man
graduate with a degree in clean balls
from manscaped
fall is here and we could all use a
stiff breeze wouldn't you agree i would
like a nice rod of stiff breeze that's
right this episode is sponsored by blue
chew guys confidence can take you far in
life it can also help in the bedroom
especially when it comes time to step up
to the plate that's where blue chew
comes in and blue chew if you don't know
what we're talking about is a unique
online service that delivers the same
active ingredients as viagra and cialis
but in chewable tablets at the fraction
of the cost so you can take them anytime
day or night you can plan ahead or be
ready whenever an opportunity arises the
process is simple sign up at
consult with one of their licensed
medical providers and once you're
approved you'll receive your
prescription within days
here's the thing you it they're chewable
it's like you already you're gonna take
the medicine and you're gonna already be
exerting a lot of effort
so
you know don't have to try to swallow
things and do that just chew it get
ready to go i mean and the best part
it's all done online so no visits to the
doctor office no awkward conversations
and no waiting in line at the pharmacy
blue chews tablets are made in the usa
and and prepared and shipped direct to
your door in a discreet package for
those of you that are worried about that
with bluechew men everywhere are excited
to see the postman because when your
package has arrived your package has
arrived so if you could benefit from
extra confidence when it's time to
perform bluetooth can help and we've got
a special deal for our listeners try
bluetooth free when you use our promo
code tuesday at checkout just pay five
dollars shipping that's bluechew.com
promo code tuesday to receive your first
month free visit bluechew.com for more
details and more and important safety
information and we thank bluechu for
sponsoring this podcast ladies baluchu
is exclusively for men but the end
result is something you'll both enjoy so
i get your man to sign up now
you guys i got my eyelashes done to look
good they look wait you've got them done
by our girl our room
no aruna doesn't do them but um
there's a girl in her place that started
doing it oh shout out by the way aruna
best eyebrow
she's in um
on la brea and santa monica so that's
just you get to wake up like that shut
up i wake up full stripper i'm like oh
that's so cool it takes me like one
minute to do my makeup it's crazy i was
late
it's so disrespect more disrespectful
than you know
this was earlier though i got this at 7
30 in the morning thinking i wake up
with such a plan you guys do you want to
know something about me that probably
most people don't know
i cannot spend the night alone
i am terrified i could have guessed that
yeah yeah so what do you do your
family's around a lot when when bobby is
out of town i need um my sister or my
mom here you know i would always i would
always drop everything and sleep over
here i would sleep in the garage i don't
care i'll sleep anywhere on the floor
dollface season two has been canceled
due to the uh disappearance of
coming back like he esther lives here
now this we have one week left i will
let's do i love sleepovers so [ __ ]
much guys
what do you do break it down for us like
what would we be doing
what
okay todd and i are in the process of
getting an arcade and a popcorn machine
a popcorn machine
shut up yeah i realized yesterday it's
like i have to live my best life and the
i we were going to go to the movies and
i was like i don't like the movies
anymore you just want the popcorn i just
want the [ __ ] i was like let's just
cut the [ __ ] middle man it's set
we're doing the sleepover and we're
getting a really big tv
one month i want hard plans he's we're
ordering the tv today popcorn machine i
guess can come too i think they're only
like 200 bucks they're not even that
much and we're so we're gonna have a
sleepover at annie's place we're gonna
take edibles we're gonna film it bring
it bring dogs to bring dogs we're gonna
taste kalila's ass we're gonna we're
gonna have an ass tasting test pre-order
what is it
well with should i start drinking again
is it good with white or red wine
i think it goes with jager
myself this [ __ ] pairs well with a
jaeger bomb
um did you ever do a jager bomb did you
ever drink at all never i've never still
never done this next i don't actually no
i'm not as more controllable yeah i'm
gonna i'm gonna chill
i you know that you've sent me into a
weed spiral because i keep thinking if
esther can
i cannot be the only one
literally i've inspired many but i'm i'm
not i can't but talk to me about it
because why don't you what's your
problem with it here's what happens okay
so i don't really like every once in a
while i smoke during the day right wait
wait wait wait
full self-doubt can we do this over a
banana break oh i wait i'm i love it but
i'm taking them i'm gonna eat your
[ __ ] i know you're attracted to my
daughter you are finally
[Music]
thank you no okay i want to hear this
why because this is my big question when
i started trying edibles i'm like why
would i always hear whitney and annie be
like i gotta stop what like why
okay it may be a personality type it may
be it's got to be like i have a
because i was thinking about it can i
get can i hypnotize myself
to smoke weed appropriately or do i need
to hit myself as myself to quit because
i'm very black and white why do you do
it what's up i go every time i consider
smoking weed every time i'm like about
to smoke we gotta go let's get the
highest we've ever [ __ ] been like i'm
never like let's get a little high i'm
always like i want to be like i want to
wake up bottomless with like a funyun
bag i want to have like my hair
extension still in
like i want the worst case scenario so
but it you're saying if you could
just take a two and a half milligram
take a [ __ ] just relax with it a little
bit then you'd be like then you could do
it all the time it'd be no big deal
right but i can't and i eat like crazy
i woke up this morning
and
i have
an empty ramen cup of soup okay
this is already bad
not like there's some noodles you know
however nobody finishes them i mean i
drank and licked the styrofoam
okay so a cup of soup those are 14 cents
14 cents by the way
that's how you say that that's how
you're rich that's how i got the popcorn
that cost 14 cents
i wonder you can get a tesla then
you can get a tesla that you have more
money than me i got a car oh yeah is
that your car out there what
it's really classier than i thought
you couldn't
you got an audi are we allowed to say um
something because what is going on why
did you get a car i have to why i've
been i've been had to for the last she's
running five years she's scared
you don't wear transportation out away
from us yeah what i'll i'll monitor the
keys i have four dogs now
that prius is not going to hold up much
longer it's always so stressful when i
have to like take them anywhere i have
no doubt you're not going to have more
dogs too
i have no doubt that four's a cow don't
put that [ __ ] on me yeah you don't put
that out in the universe because you
might be right why'd you pick that car
it was either that or like the rob four
for me because it's about the same size
and they didn't have the rav4 inventory
i guess they like they're low on the
chips the computer chips or something
that was my number one and they were
like
hey audi you know this and this and i
was like i don't deserve anything like a
luxury vehicle it's not me that's not on
brand for me because i'm a corolla type
of gal no but then i drove it
and i was like holy [ __ ] can i just say
she's wearing yeezys and a [ __ ]
corolla she's not a corolla that is her
dad talked her into some [ __ ] that's
what makes me cool the yeezy's in the
corolla
esther you're like two months away from
wearing like having a grill or something
listen [ __ ]
i know you have money
you're about to pop with this money okay
i know it your friends are too famous
it's going to happen you are you are an
interesting influence listen i will
admit i'm telling you and i think you're
rubbing off on koloko as well she got an
audi
i went in as an esther i left as a nanny
that's from the car dealership no i was
very impressed it was a little tame of a
color are you wearing celine sunglasses
yes [ __ ] why do you can't put them on
right now can i just tell you i've
wanted a pair of saline sunglasses let's
go get them today let's leave let's
leave right now let's cut this short
where did you go get them
that's embarrassing why is that
embarrassing because it was a sunglass
hut
i bought them like a poor [ __ ]
wait is this san close santa claus is
just not good it's not good were they
there were 400 yeah
but i looked at
600 so then that felt time glitching
you have to try on the most expensive
sunglasses first and then the rest of
them seem so cheap
i'm just leasing them though
do we have some fan audio questions this
week george we do
all right the first question here is
from andrew shanti we love our voice
legs
hi annie esther and kalyla i have a
hypothetical question for you if you had
the option to go back in time would you
do it and how far back would you want to
go love the podcast thanks a lot
thanks andrew you know my answer is yes
100 i would just go back to like
i think she would take a
johnny space rocket back in time
definitely go all the way back to
elementary school oh elementary yeah and
do it all you saw that picture she
posted she was the [ __ ] king kenya
that school which picture your little
gangster like kindergarten picture
that you posted i didn't remember that
but i was cool yeah what's your favorite
track she picked in third grade
that is bad what's your favorite time
travel movie of all time back to the
future one and two
for sure someone was saying that isn't a
good movie and i can't allow that that's
there's this one that's really good with
rachel mcadams it's called about time
and i
bawled my eyes out when i watched never
cried more in my life right i've i cried
from the minute it started to i could
cry you know why his daddy issues daddy
issues i sat next to one of my
boyfriends i can't remember it was like
i always go on a first date i went on a
first date to precious the movie
precious
it was the same amount of crying and
horror
i was like
like my snot like you when you're
hyperventilating during bubbles yeah
beautiful
about time is so good yesterday i think
you'll like that okay should we watch on
our sleepover yes
we better get a hard date for the
sleepover okay because it's pissing me
off but it doesn't happen answer
andrew's question annie this morning
when i was getting that starbucks
and i would just say to myself that
you're not gonna be early just
lower the standards
you're going to yell at gps if you keep
this up you're going to be yelling at a
gps
no um i
i would like to go back in time
to the other night when i was talking to
my ex-boyfriend and i said my first
boundary and i would like to say a
couple i would like to go like this you
know what dude shut the [ __ ] up yeah i
don't [ __ ] hear you talk anymore i
[ __ ] told you i didn't want to hear
this and i'm [ __ ] tired of like
trying to make you feel good it's
[ __ ] annoying you haven't listened to
anything i said and i'm [ __ ] out
[ __ ] and then flicked a joint in his
face
that's amazing that's what i was that's
a great answer i was mad at my i was
like oh i wish i'd been harder you know
it's not as good of an answer as
reliving your entire elementary school
but it's pretty good it's pretty
predictable too
i want to go back in time to when my
family doctor fisted my [ __ ] but me
too
kalila's definitely like there's she
said screaming for help over here
what's going on
i want to go back in time to when i was
about a year old and there's this video
of oh my goodness stealing um we were
having a family party and i stole a
chicken drumstick
and my nanny was screaming like she has
a drumstick and i shove it i go into bed
and i shove it under a pillow and i like
sleep on it
there's something very magical and real
and true to my character in that moment
that i kind of want to relive where i'm
like what does that all mean why did i
think i had to steal food and why did i
shove it and try to hide it it's just so
weird because bobby is
he does have a likeness to a drumstick
he does the body type of a drumstick
rotisserie chicken yeah he died very
chickeny why was it magical um when i
look back at it just the thrill you
could see how excited i was about
feeling like i had done something that i
was gonna i was getting yelled at
actually i don't think i was one i think
i was like two you want to go back to
feeling bad about something you did yeah
like
people chasing me was really fun and
like negative attention so you're saying
is that what it is that's what it
sounded like i am sensing there's
something about your imagination that
was
really enjoying that moment and that you
want to have this like imaginative fun
experience like that maybe another thing
i would go back to is did you ever
threaten to run away
yes from home and did you yes no one
knows i ran behind a tree famously and
you and you look and you were waiting
for them to find and they're just like
cooking dinner yes famously i ran away
no one noticed and i just came home and
that was how long
40 minutes
poor esther
but i have a similar
this is it's making me think of it this
is sad it's kind of funny but
i really wanted a sink in my room
i like really wanted my own sink
and so i would do the creepiest thing
where i would put a bowl of water in a
drawer
and i would just pretend that that was
like my sink i would open the drawer why
did you want i don't want to sing i know
we have to investigate i don't know we
can get to it we can't how old were you
i don't know were you jacob the dog at
this time i was older than jacob the dog
i was probably like you know fourth ish
grade something like that okay we're
getting to being pretty old for this um
did you like watching your mom do dishes
or something no i think it was like i
wanted up my own bathroom sink and
that i could just play i loved playing
with water because water was it's so
weird to bathe so little but love to
play with water i know i want to confess
something
i am
doing something annie which i think you
might find interesting and is that i've
completely stopped watching any porn at
all
and i'm trying to get back to a place of
just my imagination and i'm now because
i'm trying to like reconnect with the
blood flow into my vagina right yeah
yeah yeah and mister's listening what's
happening
is if you because there's so many things
that these centers on the edge of her
seat and about to slip off it
so no more vibrators no more nothing
maybe i do know vibrators so i'm
completely like re-sensitized so like i
could come to a picture of some of a
man's hand so my thing now is i am
fapping
fully [ __ ] coming to pictures of male
hands
i've i've i've gone completely amish
and now it's like this is like a foot
fetish
you're gonna start just squirting yeah
are you gonna be having a trouble having
troubles out in the world when you see
man hands i think so now and by the way
does it count if they have fingernails
on them
one time i was wearing press-on nails to
thanksgiving and my uncle said that i
looked like i had transvestite hands and
i always think that now
when i was a nursing student um
the korean ladies that i would um if
they when they were patients they would
always grab my hand and be like oh you
have really pretty hands take care of
them and um i felt so honored because if
the asian ladies know about skin care
and good hands and i think that's
because i sweat so much they've been
kept lubricated my whole life
for sure hands are a thing i think you
just don't even think about until
they're gone and they go oh
[ __ ]
man's hands are hot they are they're hot
there's no question because you guys
come to a picture of a man's hand
absolutely not like torn up you know
like when they're just biting and
nervous they're so nervous to be around
me so it'll not do it for me but i'm so
jealous of yours current sexuality send
me man hands no more dick pics that does
not work for me man hands there's a
certain like there's a certain type of
calf too that's really hot on a guy for
sure
um
my neighbor growing up my friend matt
like was so hot like he was just so he
was like my type and then it just
everything was hot that was like him
forever and todd definitely has like
that's all of it he's just like todd's
just like tall and cute i mean he
definitely like we smoke weed and eat
some [ __ ] but
i gotta like i gotta i can't control my
eating i gotta say wait how did you make
that transition
what
from talking about how hot your
boyfriend is i just started thinking
about how fat we're getting i was like
oh god we're getting fat i heard a new
tip for if you smoke weed to not get the
munchies as you uh rinse your mouth out
with listerine oh all right does that
really work yeah
when you get horny you just douche with
it yeah how does that help it's it cuts
the mouth like it's the wheat in your
mouth that makes you hungry it's like
the enzymes or something oh my god i
love that try it out will you let us
know i start chugging it i relapse on
the alcohol
will you let us know annie that works
yeah do we have another question george
question from brit hey you filthy little
slugs yes
my question is have you ever eaten out a
man's [ __ ]
and if you have let's hear the story and
if not let's hear your thoughts
i was about to eat a man's [ __ ] out
a woman with man's shoulders just
kidding that's true um i don't i'm not
an [ __ ] leader myself
i'm not either look at my face this is
the face of an [ __ ] you have those um
d
a
e's
wait i mean a a d
no instead of asl i was trying to say a
e ls a e ls yeah aeols that's my girl
a b c d i know i have to do the whole
alphabet to get to that basically really
ael i can't ass eating lips that's what
we made up instead of instead of dick
sucking lips
somehow the universe just gives me gems
i'm not even gonna tell you why that's a
gem but it's a gem anyways look at this
tell us why it's a gem i'll tell you
after but i starts to leave i'm gonna
find out and she's never gonna know
that's fine
you're over fomo
oh my god weed is a cure i never thought
weed was a medicine until now it's a
medicine for me i doze her with it i
have a question for you guys so if dave
and todd was like were like hey it's
just
this really turns me off
yes that's what i'm saying then you are
an [ __ ] eater
it's just it's whether it's you know a
lot of men that i've been with don't ask
for that but it's just i'm game for
anything well it depends on the guy too
because i i've definitely dated a guy
where it's like you can see and he sucks
and he's not like worried about me
coming in anyway and then he's like i
can see him sort of like inching his
[ __ ] closer to my face when i'm
blowing i'm like no no no we're not
doing a hip thrust where your asshole's
not no you're not we you've done nothing
for me all right this is gonna sound
right i'm gonna go to your ass while
you've done nothing for me that is
okay that is this is gonna sound so
superficial but i don't like it when men
arch their back no it's gay i'm sorry
it's gay
i'm sorry okay
cancel me for the truth cancel me for
the truth okay even if they're going
down on this [ __ ] ship okay but i
will not go down on a man that arches
his back here's what i'll say okay if a
guy is going down on me and if i look
this way and his ass is arched as he's
eating me out i am
for some reason that doesn't work for me
flatten your bodies and you're like i'd
rather cow than cat if you know what i
mean
i'd rather cow than cat i'd rather have
you arched in a way that looks like you
your ass is pushing in yes cow we need
cow no cat please no cat try to just be
regular please like which one is cow and
which in his cat
is up like this and cat wait cat is
arched cat has to be arched right yeah
are you trying to say i gotta say
esther's heard of yoga i don't know if
she's
she looks cute in the clothes i don't
know if she's ever
sweating in them here's another thing i
i uh planned for us on our trip to
hawaii we're doing uh a yoga session
with my favorite yoga instructor kara
she's going to lead a session and we're
going to record it oh i love that yeah
that's great amazing anything you want
me to do i'll do yeah we're going to do
it anything is this getting planned for
real yes esther everybody schedules work
so we're returning boys we are bringing
boys
yeah because we cannot be left to our
own david is coming because dave wants
to go to yeah i can't go to hawaii
without my we're going yeah i don't know
if bobby can come but he's gonna
do you think people are gonna think
todd's hawaiian mm-hmm he's a local boy
he's so cute i'll make him climb up a
tree and get me a coconut
i have to go to work uh
johnny rockets calls johnny rockets no i
doll face it's our last week um
my parting words are thank you so much i
love you guys so much and i will eat
your ass and i swear if we don't get a
[ __ ] sleepover and a trip to hawaii
and i'll even throw out the vegas thing
on the book soon
you're quitting i'm quitting the show so
will you eat my ass out in my tesla
i will
you know what if you if you listen to me
annie you stick it out from the window
and i will eat it from outside now i
already want to get the one with these
ones because i wanted to i wanted to
like
i want this
to come end of december
okay exciting we're gonna just gang bang
we'll just go back to we have to figure
out the wrap also do you guys want to
get a billboard
on a bus stop yeah in k-town yeah let's
get a billboard okay
yeah let's get a billboard i want a
billboard
george george get us a billboard now
[ __ ] billboard if you're gonna start
dressing up like us get to the [ __ ]
building have fun at work have fun so i
had all your famous rich friends oh my
god
our little hollywood starlet
i had cat cow pulled up that's so funny
what you just said so funny so basically
this let me show you guys what what i
don't want when i
get eaten out okay all right for all the
audio listeners annie is on her back uh
they're a long ways for money
microphones kalila is this is what i
don't want andy is spreading her legs
that your ass is sticking out like yeah
and then i don't want to i shouldn't be
able to see your ass over your shoulder
very much like a cow pose and yoga
so i want just a little more arch and
then flatten your legs on the bend okay
like this
forgot to take those because you're
perching your ass when you get [ __ ] by
a boy do you understand you're perching
your [ __ ] to get [ __ ] by men which
is totally okay that's totally okay and
also by the way
bye guys you get the most [ __ ] we know
it okay we know that you get the most
[ __ ] by men but
it's because we're leaning into the arch
but it's like when we're when i'm trying
to like when i want a [ __ ]
[Music]
rod okay it cannot be delivered with an
ass that's puckered and ready to go
penetrated
for me i'm not you can do that but
here's another thing i've been thinking
about with kink shaming and stuff
okay so
obviously everybody you probably all
know that i i pixelate my feet because
men are always asking for pictures my
feet and i found it i was on wiki feet
and it just like freaked me out i didn't
realize i had this like genital
that was exposed
and
so now i'm saving my feet for my general
awareness cowboys
[Laughter]
my genital is covered by a cowboy
of cow cowpos my point was when when the
foot fetish people get mad at me for
pixelating my feet it's like first of
all it's a the reason it's like it
doesn't exist if it's accepted yeah the
hot part is that it's weird and people
don't like it you know what i mean like
that is what a kink is yeah like if we
all were like okay and it's not like i
don't care what people do to other
people's bodies that are consenting it's
like not my problem but
if you want you can't have my feet you
can and but also it's kind of up the
value of your feet a little bit sure
yeah so i think it's a very um a very
good marketing strategy in my opinion
let's add some zeros to this one
and you can see these feet okay and this
hand will turn into a foot real quick
would you eat [ __ ] even if it killed
you i don't know
her saying that her [ __ ] is cleaner
than her outside is cannot be correct i
just want to know i i think i need to
know around stinky genitals i need to
know how you wipe
if i see her one time wiping back to
front it's over i know her entire
routine of [ __ ] cleaning and i am out
well here's the thing i do not have a
bidet
right okay but i will never i i do
mechanical mechanical filipinos do me
i'll show you a great mechanical
cleaning with a cable table yeah what's
it called
it's like this thing we um
it's like a you can use anything a water
bottle or you can use like a cup
and i'll teach you guys the technique
next time let's show it we should show
it just you need mechanical washing this
looks like the cure to hemorrhoids that
i found on youtube have you ever had a
hemi of course i i think there aren't
they for life
you can get a hemorrhoidectomy
you get them removed if it bothers you
because i had a friend who had um
um a little cherry down there and it was
really starting to like pop out and she
had to push it back in and it hurt her a
lot like the friction and the dryness
i've never had like painful hemorrhoids
you're lucky because they can hurt a lot
i'm very lucky listen when it comes to
hemorrhoids
i'm a [ __ ] lucky ass [ __ ] okay i
haven't had i don't have one yet i'm
sure i have a lot of internal ones i
think everyone does i i do feel like um
i've learned my lessons like you can't
sit on the toilet too long you
definitely can't there's there's a
feeling of a stretch that you know
something's going wrong you're tearing
something and something will come in its
place
something will fill it it's like
a baby
a little
tiny little baby a tiny little
a mini hemi all right guys this has been
so fun esther's abandoned us uh for
hollywood
are you guys a cat or are you a cow
comment below thank you guys so much for
watching please like subscribe tell your
friends tell your girlfriends tell your
boyfriends tell everyone we're here we
made this all for you
please enjoy bye guys
[Music]
oh good good hey sorry what time is it
over there
six in the morning
oh [ __ ] this is very important we're
glad we woke you up this is not the
question you want to hear at six in the
morning i don't think
give it a go why not let's have a crack
okay speaking of crack
you're very on brand
um i just want to know because i've
never had a point of reference before
and i've never had anyone tell me
anything in regards to how i actually
taste
because um but i wanted to know
if you can remember what my [ __ ]
tastes like
the delicious
maybe this is what he wanted to wake up
to
okay okay you can you're free to expand
on how delicious
on a scale of battery acid and uh
uh
triple a to del to a d battery yeah
double d battery double d battery okay
what's a double what does that even mean
um definitely up there don't i don't
just go down on any random
chick
it's gonna have to be my partner's ass
so
you're definitely up there i'll tell you
that much so oh this is like a
like a
romantic comedy right now okay i am
swaying so much right now i have to hang
up thank you so much for answering that
question and um
um i'll i'll hit you up later to
apologize okay
thank you i'm gonna pull out my laptop
now and the porno channel's coming on
yeah he's definitely like so hard
all right i'll hit you up later
okay all right
you sound so hot
i've never seen i don't know if i've
seen an ugly australian man
he's not ugly i just couldn't really
deal with the pressure of that i thought
he might say it wasn't good
i was stressed i was stressed the
opposite happened and how did it make
you feel
caught off guard because i wasn't i he
would have been like it was fine i
didn't know he would say delicious maybe
this is time for you to realize i'm
delicious that you
yeah your image of yourself is not
accurate it doesn't match those around
you
maybe this is a this is a groundbreaking
moment for you maybe maybe my ass is
delicious george
and maybe i should
have him speak to bobby and say hey
her ass is delicious give it a whirl
and so do you think you've taken on
bobby not wanting to eat [ __ ] as him
not wanting to eat your ass yes
yes you've taken something personally i
took it pers i have been taking it
personally and it's just not something
that he likes to do ever for anyone i
don't think if jesus came down and
spread his cheeks apart and said bobby i
need you to eat my ass i don't think
bobby would he's grossed out by it he
just doesn't want to do it but that's
the truth i just didn't i didn't know
that was the truth now i know it might
yeah maybe you need to be like listen
i'm top on the menu in australia
okay the vegemite comes second to my
[ __ ] okay
i got the veggie munch right here all
right i love how you call it vegemite
what is that vegemite vegemite vegemite
i don't know i always imagine being
veggie might like oh that actually
sounds so gross it might be veggie